rick wilson the co-founder of the
lincoln project a political platform by
current and former republicans who aim
to prevent the re-election of donald
trump is with us today rick great seeing
you again
thank you and it's a pleasure to be with
you rick so with all the legal
challenges hanging over his head will
donald trump speed up his announcement
to run again in 2024
i believe he will i think he perceives
announcing a run for president as a way
of protecting himself from legal
consequences of his behavior i think he
views it as something that will activate
his base
uh and will will simultaneously protect
him from the legal jeopardy which he's
placed himself but also will reunite the
republican party behind him and
eliminate all these pesky wannabes like
ron desantis and ted cruz and josh
hawley
who are all planning to run for
president if trump does not
so let's assume he is announcing it
fairly soon what would that mean exactly
for these challengers or possible
challenges of his
it it means they're all going to become
afterthoughts very quickly
they know it and he knows it he has a
clear memory of 2016
and you had a field of 17 highly
qualified charismatic organized
well-funded republican candidates and he
took them apart one by one uh and i
think we would see the same thing he has
a unique bond with the republican base
that is seemingly unshakable
and that that bond is
as long as the republican base sticks
with him at the level they do
it makes it very difficult for anybody
else to win a primary against him even
if only 35 percent of republicans want
trump
that's 35 that are going to stick with
him no matter what and if you've got a
crowded field of multiple candidates
he's going to have a very strong
competitive advantage in that regard
is there anything anything which could
come out of this search which would kind
of bring him into trouble within the
republican party
i mean look we have seen a long arc over
the last seven years of donald trump
engaging in outrageous and egregious
behavior
engaging in illegal behavior engaging in
behavior that would disqualify any other
candidate and
right now the republican party is so
traumatized by this at the leadership
level they don't know what to do but
they are fearful of trump's base they do
not want to cross trump or his base and
now that fox news is coming back all in
for donald trump it's a much more
difficult equation
um for for for any other you know
political figure to even calculate what
they would do to run against him it's
going to strengthen him
in a very meaningful way with the base
and that's all he really cares about
when do you think he will announce his
candidacy
look i we're hearing that he's under
tremendous pressure to not do it before
the election
um and generally when you pressure
donald trump did not do something he
goes ahead and does it so i think we
could probably expect it sooner than
later okay
rick i'm just coming back from cpec this
is for international audience the annual
meeting of the right-wing branch of the
republican party and yes i was actually
really shocked
about
the radical rhetoric and i've been to a
couple of cpacs before
is this now representative of the whole
republican party
it's certainly representative of a
majority i believe in the republican
party and
and the people that are remaining in the
republican party
for them it's not a deal breaker to have
the what i call the victor orban wing of
the republican party
um which is aggressively white
nationalist aggressively anti-immigrant
um you know cruel conspiratorial crazy
um it's not a deal breaker for the rest
of republicans they sort of shrug and
now go yeah we get second smith to have
those guys during our coalition and i
think that is a really deadly kind of of
decision for the gop to have made um but
it's one that that quite clearly they
are comfortable with at some level
i was surprised how much the focus on
the lgbtq plus issue why that
the culture war is the same is the
single most underpinning factor in the
republican party
um they have they have their their their
their a post-policy party on almost
every other issue
except for the fact that they want to be
very very involved in
in the lgbtq question
in part because of meaningful fraction
of the republican base is that
evangelical nationalist populist cohort
and they believe that they're going to
win the culture war and they're going to
make homosexuality go away and make the
lgbt community vanish by regulating them
out of existence i think this is a
a grotesque and and sickening um set of
beliefs but it is certainly something
that is driving a lot of behavior inside
the republican party it's why they
associate anyone who's lgbt with
pedophilia it's why they talk about
grooming it's why they do all these
things that are that are
of course untrue
but that have a resonance in the culture
space that the evangelical christian
community operates in
so rick you know the republican party
very well do you see anybody anybody uh
who has an any realistic option
in this country to kind of know i don't
even have to finish my no yeah i mean i
i and as i talk about this question
almost every day with folks um who you
know from ex-republicans to well-meaning
democrats to media people to academics
and the republican party has been
fundamentally altered
in a way that i think is probably
permanent
uh i think there is a crying need in
america
for a center-right party
that believes in individual liberty and
free markets and the constitution and
the rule of law but that's not today's
republican party
that party doesn't exist right now
um except as an operating division of
donald trump's ambition and ego
um
where that's going to emerge will a
conservative third party emerge i don't
know that answer that right i mean
there's just the third party kind of
evolving does this have any chance do
you think uh the the the new third party
that's been announced i think is a
fool's errand i don't they they
announced a party before they announced
any sort of perspective or policy or
beliefs which means they're going to try
to trim themselves into some sort of
thing in the middle
and honestly americans respond good and
bad
to people who act from belief and
principle
you know a lot of people
disrespect and dislike donald trump but
they believe that donald trump
represents their principles
a lot of people dislike joe biden or
barack obama but they believe they
represent their principles they are
drawn to principle uh the idea that
there's a set of
principles driving a leader
that's not what happens in the in the
third parties right now that come out of
america they seem like they're
deliberately trying to to sand down all
the rough edges and say oh i'm just good
enough you know we won't offend you one
way or the other
so can we just you know hopefully
steal your vote it's not going to work
that way
with this forward party it's just it's
and look uh my partner in the in the
lincoln project reid galen and i have
both been around third party politics in
america it is not like a european
parliamentary democracy it is not like
you know other countries where multiple
parties are the rule of the land it is
very much a duopoly in the political
parties in america and it's hard to
break people out of their cultural
silos and get them to consider a third
party option
rick my last question before i let you
go given the growing distrust in the
political institutions are you concerned
about political uprisings or violent
uprisings before
or after the next election
and as we have seen already in america a
rise in political violence on the right
and that political violence took a toll
on january 6.
it uh it it actually happened again
yesterday when an armed gunman attacked
an fbi office in ohio why because he was
told
by the entire right-wing propaganda
machine that the country is under attack
that trump is under attack and they have
to take immediate steps i am deeply
concerned about the rise of political
violence in the u.s and and and
anytime a a political system becomes
inflected with the option of using
violence to achieve a political end
it is profoundly unstable profoundly
dangerous and cannot be called a
republic or a or a democratic republic
in any context it is increasingly
it is increasingly
relevant to the lives of american people
that the mob on the side of the trump
equation
is using the rhetoric of violence they
are stepping up the threats of violence
and we are seeing increasing acts of
violence this is a spectrum we need to
find a way to check and stop as quickly
as we can it is a deep concern to me and
many others what can be done
look you have to raise the stakes in
america
of of being in that nationalist populist
pro-violence cohort you have to make
them unelectable you have to find ways
to tell people that if they
if they think they're electing a
republican because that's what they've
been all their lives they need to look
more closely at who those people are now
i i often analogize that today's
republican party to like those creatures
that parasites in the jungle will will
take over its brain and eat it from the
inside out that's what's happened to the
gop and people who still sort of have a
vestigial alliance or allegiance to the
republican party are not voting for the
republican party of george bush or
ronald reagan or or eisenhower
or teddy roosevelt they're voting for a
republican party that is profoundly
different than that and is engaged in
again conspiracy cruelty craziness
violence at a level that we've never
seen in the u.s before
rick
let's keep this conversation going and
wish i had better news
but um thank you very much again for
your insight and absolutely i'm happy to
be with you anytime thank you very much
thanks